das ist wirklich eine mittelschwere
katastrophe schon wieder zeigt sich wie
sorglos die behörden in deutschland mit
wahlen umgehen die software mit der die
meisten wahlergebnisse an die
landeswahlleiter übermittelt werden die
ist total unsicher und jetzt auch noch
mit einfachsten mitteln gehackt worden
und ich muss sagen das ganze fühlt sich
für mich an wie eine wiederholungstat
wie ein déjà vu dabei hätte man aus dem
debakel mit den wahlcomputern lernen
können inzwischen sind sie durch das
bundesverfassungsgericht verboten worden
und das dürfte wahrscheinlich auch jetzt
die konsequenz sein was jetzt passiert
warum die bundestagswahl die gefahr ist
jetzt wirklich zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
ja es war der skandal 2008 bei der
landtagswahl in hessen wurden
wahlcomputer eingesetzt die ganz einfach
zu manipulieren waren der umgang mit
ihnen war nämlich unglaublich sorglos
die wahlcomputer wurden in der nacht vor
der wahl bei parteipolitikern gelagert
die papier siegel der geräte konnten
fotokopiert werden und den schlüssel für
den kasten in dem der computer steckte
den gab es im internet in wenigen
minuten konnte man den kasten öffnen und
den computer darin manipulieren das
passwort baugleicher geräte in den
niederlanden lautete geheim und stand im
quellcode das bundesverfassungsgericht
verbot die geräte sie erfüllten nicht
die kriterien einer öffentlichen
auszählung manipulationen hätten durch
wahlhelfer nicht aufgedeckt werden
können aber jetzt kommt es noch
schlimmer die software die in den
meisten fällen für die übermittlung der
wahlergebnisse eingesetzt wird ist um es
deutlich zu sagen griff absoluter müll
ich glaube diese bewertung ist wirklich
nicht übertrieben dabei sollte man nicht
vergessen dass die abwicklung einer wahl
ziemlich einfach es ist tradition nicht
mehr und nicht weniger als das zählen
und addieren von stimmen das wird in
jedem wahlkreis gemacht dann wieder auf
kommunaler ebene und so weiter und so
fort bis das bundes wahlergebnis
feststellen also wirklich kein hexenwerk
aber selbst das kann man so richtig
verbocken wie eine untersuchung jetzt
zeigt sie zeit berichtet aktuell über
den informatiker martin scheel sich der
den wahnsinn aufgedeckt hat und der geht
so pc wahl so heißt die software ist
laut hersteller das meistgenutzte wahl
organisationssystem in deutschen
verwaltungen das programm ist eigentlich
nicht für privatpersonen zugänglich aber
tschersich findet teile der software im
netz und zwar so er findet erst mal im
netz das passwort für den servicebereich
einer firma die pc wahl vertreibt dort
kann er die bedienungsanleitung
herunterladen in dieser anleitung stehen
die zugangsdaten des internen service
bereich des herstellers von pc wahl
achtung nutzername service kennwort pcb
kunde wort jetzt kann der teile der
software laden und er kommt auf die
erste gravierende sicherheitslücke wir
hatten ja gerade festgestellt wahlen
sind nicht mehr und nicht weniger als
addition es werden steht
addiert und genau das macht pc wahl und
wie auch dass es ganz einfach per
tabellenkalkulation die tabellen die pc
wahl
dabei generiert die sind vollkommen
ungeschützt niemand kann überprüfen ob
sie echt oder manipuliert sind es ist
also das einfachste sie abzufangen zu
manipulieren und weiterzuschicken die
landeswahlleiter würden absolut nichts
bemerken die nächste bombe städte und
gemeinden müssen das programm
aktualisieren
die zugangsdaten dafür hat er sich auch
im netz gefunden fdp war theoretisch
könnte er damit eine manipulierte
version der software dort hochladen und
die kommunen würden sie herunterladen
und einsetzen das wäre der absolute
supergau nächste katastrophe die
software verschickt die dateien aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht über das
internet super sondern über ein internes
netzwerk der einmal punkt dafür ist
allerdings in der software
einprogrammiert aber immerhin passwort
geschützt aber was soll ich sagen auch
in trance sich zumindest für hessen
herausgefunden dass lautet achtung es
der hessische landeswahlleiter hat jetzt
reagiert und eine anordnung erlassen die
wahlhelfer sollen auf der öffentlichen
internet seite überprüfen ob ihre
ergebnisse korrekt übermittelt wurden
wie bitte das kind soll also erst in den
brunnen fallen und dann herausgezogen
werden
entschuldigung wir sind die dänen darauf
das wäre doch die absolute katastrophe
wenn im nachhinein ergebnisse korrigiert
werden müssten
jetzt hat der entwickler eine neue
version des programms mit neuen
sicherheitsmechanismen versprochen der
hamburger chaos computer club hat sich
das genau angesehen fazit die neue
version ist ungeeignet die
schwachstellen zu beseitigen
der bundeswahlleiter hat jetzt für den
notfall telefonische meldekette
einrichten lassen um die ergebnisse
zuverlässig zu übermitteln herzlich
willkommen in der steinzeit ich fürchte
dass der notfall bereits eingetreten ist
in unserem hochtechnologie land werden
wir am 24 september vielleicht etwas auf
die wahlergebnisse warten müssen
ihr könnt übrigens ab sofort bei pixum
mitmachen und werdet auch als
mitwirkende genannt clixoom braucht
untertitel damit auch menschen den
anderen ländern die videos anschauen
können ihr könnt untertitel in jeder
sprache machen
zu den los
hab ich freue mich über eure mitarbeit
hierbei klicks und ich euch natürlich
auf dem laufenden zu diesem thema auch
in den kommentaren
wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollte
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergessen ich den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit bedroht
künstliche intelligenz die menschheit oh
man im moment müsste es allerdings
heißen bedroht die menschliche
intelligenz oder dummheit vielmehr die
menschheit ansonsten bis dann badran und
vor allem geht wählen